Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Le peintre Léonard de Vinci
a eu le sculpteur Andréa de Verrocchio
comme mentor.
La sculptrice Camille Claudel a eu Rodin.
La célèbre designer Charlotte Perriand
a eu l'architecte Le Corbusier.
Dans le film Disney Kung Fu Panda,
le panda Po a eu maître Shifu.
Et vous, avez-vous un mentor ?
Pouvez-vous lever la main
si vous pensez en avoir eu un,
en avoir un
ou avoir une source d’inspiration
majeure, un parrain, une marraine,
quelqu’un qui vous a enseigné
beaucoup de choses ?
Comme la moitié environ de la salle,
je n’aurais pas su répondre
jusqu’à récemment.
D’abord parce que je ne
m’étais pas posé la question
et ensuite parce que
je n’aurais pas su répondre.
Ça n’est qu’en devenant,
assez récemment, en octobre,
présidente de l’association de mon master
que j’ai commencé à avoir besoin d’une
figure de référence pour apprendre d’elle,
pour comprendre comment j’allais manager
cette équipe dans un projet commun.
Peut-être que vous avez endossé des rôles
similaires dans votre équipe sportive,
votre propre association,
votre parti politique,
toute équipe possible, sportive ou autre.
Vous avez été un peu
chef d’orchestre d’un projet
et vous avez fait face aussi
à apprendre ce management sur le tas ?
Ou peut-être pas, peut-être que vous
avez vécu d’autres situations ou rôles.
Ou en tout cas,
vous aviez vécu à ce moment-là
de l’enthousiasme
et en même temps de l’appréhension,
comme si vous n’en n’étiez pas
forcément capable ou légitime.
En tout cas, c’est ce que
je découvrais à ce moment-là.
Et la première personne à qui j’ai pensé,
qui pouvait peut-être m’apporter
des outils vis-à-vis de ça,
c’est ma grand-mère,
qui est, encore aujourd’hui,
présidente de son entreprise, à 80 ans,
et qui m’enseigne beaucoup de choses.
Et en même temps, je remarquais qu’elle
m’avait inspirée à d’autres moments.
Qu’à chaque fois, j’utilisais
ce qu’elle m’avait appris,
je le transformais pour agir
à ma manière, dans mon époque,
pas forcément comme elle l'avait fait.
La première chose dont je voudrais parler,
là où elle m’a beaucoup inspirée,
c’est l’engagement.
Quand j’avais environ 17 ans,
j’ai commencé à comprendre
que bien que les filles et les garçons
aient en théorie les mêmes droits,
en pratique,
ce n’était pas tout à fait ça.
Mon entourage ne comprenait pas forcément
mon intérêt soudain pour ce sujet.
C’est : « Ah, les théories du genre...
De quoi elle se passionne d’un coup ?
Qu’est-ce que c’est ? »
Alors que pour ma grand-mère, c’était
évident, et même normal à mon âge,
avec les idéaux de la jeunesse
et de l’énergie,
de s’engager pour une cause
qui nous tenait à cœur,
en l’occurrence ici, l’égalité des sexes.
Elle commença à me raconter
de plus en plus des anecdotes,
ce qu’elle avait fait dans ce domaine-là.
Elle voulait que je comprenne qu’être
une femme ne devait pas m’arrêter,
qu’elle-même n’avait jamais admis
que ça puisse la freiner
dans son parcours universitaire
ou ensuite dans son cursus professionnel,
dans son accès à des métiers dans
la micro-électronique, son domaine.
Elle a vraiment voulu que je comprenne
qu’elle-même, dans ses expériences,
avait fait abstraction de ce sexe qui
pouvait parfois peut-être être dérangeant.
À l’avocate Gisèle Halimi,
qui était venue inaugurer
l’Institut polytechnique de Grenoble
avec Laurent Fabius
et qui demanda à ma grand-mère :
« Alors qu’est-ce que ça fait d’être
la seule femme dans cette équipe,
dans cet institut ? »
Elle lui répondit du tac au tac :
« Mais ma présence n’a rien à voir ici
avec mon sexe. »
Cette réponse, un peu sur la défensive,
elle la regrette peut-être aujourd’hui,
mais c’était vraiment pour ne pas briller
à côté de ses collègues masculins,
ne pas se faire éjecter du club et faire
comprendre que chacun avait sa place
à force de travail et de persévérance.
Elle remarquait mon engagement
de plus en plus féministe et politisé
car j’étais peinée de voir les extrêmes
monter en France à ce moment-là -
il y a quelques années.
Elle commençait à me motiver
en m’envoyant des petits mots du type :
« The world needs you. »
Ça a fonctionné parce que, soutenue
par son regard qui me légitimait,
qui m’encourageait,
j’ai commencé à prendre part
à une campagne présidentielle,
à m'engager pour des causes modérées.
J’ai donné une conférence
à King’s College London
pour inciter les femmes à prendre
leur place dans leur domaine,
particulièrement dans les sciences,
où elles sont parfois
sous-estimées et sous-représentées.
en parlant plus amplement
du parcours de ma grand-mère.
Aujourd’hui, j’essaie de continuer
à exploiter le dessin, la parole, les mots
pour motiver à prendre sa place
dans des domaines,
à s’engager
et à continuer de nourrir une vision d’un
monde grand, exponentiel et solidaire.
La 2e chose dont je voulais parler,
et en quoi elle m’a beaucoup inspirée,
c’était dans son rapport au travail.
Moi, j’ai eu la chance de vivre
dans une famille
qui m’a donné accès à de très belles
études, en droit et en histoire de l’art,
en France et en Angleterre.
Quand j’ai compris que j’avais envie
de moins mettre
mon diplôme, mon bac+5
au service d’entreprises
et de plus exploiter
des activités d’écriture, de dessin,
d’être plus créative
et moins au service d’entreprises,
j’ai eu du mal à me l’autoriser :
« Mais non, je vais être infidèle
à ces beaux diplômes que je pourrais
mettre au service d’entreprises. »
Ma grand-mère me poussait constamment
à mettre mon diplôme de droit
au service de sa propre entreprise.
N’ayant pas une idée concrète
de ce que je voulais faire,
je me laissais aller d’expérience
juridique en expérience juridique
qui étaient extrêmement
professionnalisantes et intéressantes,
mais dans lesquelles je ne prenais pas
beaucoup de plaisir
et de satisfaction personnelle.
Mais de quoi pouvais-je
me plaindre vraiment ?
Avais-je le droit de me plaindre ?
À côté, je sentais bien
que les choses de groupe,
ça me faisait vraiment vibrer.
C’est là où je me disais :
« J’ai envie de le faire avec
d’autres gens et pouvoir collaborer. »
Ma grand-mère, elle, je le voyais bien,
elle avait trimé pendant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale dans laquelle elle est née.
Elle n’avait pas eu le droit forcément
d’accéder à des études de cette envergure.
Elle avait pourtant dévié
de ce que son père lui proposait -
de rester au foyer, comme sa sœur aînée.
Elle avait poursuivi
des études en s’amusant.
C’était ça qui la distinguait :
s’amuser, voir avec un prisme ludique
et de découverte sa matière
qui pouvait être d’apparence - la
micro-électronique - rude et compliquée.
Et pourtant, elle ne s’est pas
laissé démonter.
Elle était parmi les deux femmes dans sa
promo de 80 hommes en maths physique,
puis plus jeune professeur de France,
et enfin a relancé des activités
avec beaucoup de courage.
Depuis 25 ans, elle a toujours son
entreprise dans la micro-électronique,
qui rassemble des visionnaires
partout dans le monde.
C’était la deuxième chose sur laquelle
elle m’a beaucoup inspirée,
ce travail en s'amusant.
C’est en allant la voir
à Grenoble il y a un an,
que j’ai vu ce jeu en action.
Elle se levait à 6 h du matin,
parlait avec ses collègues chinois,
puis dans la journée avec les Européens
qui s’étaient réveillés entre-temps,
et le soir avec les Américains, dans un
anglais comme un poisson dans l’eau.
Tout ça en s’amusant, en faisant
quelques longueurs de piscine,
en prenant un apéro avec sa copine
Jacqueline, en faisant un peu de basket.
Il y avait une facilité.
Je comprenais que si je mettais
mon énergie au bon endroit,
dans ce qui me passionnait vraiment,
je pouvais aussi avoir cette vitalité
et prendre du plaisir à ce que je faisais.
Je l’ai remerciée de m’avoir embarquée
dans ces projets avec elle,
mais je suis rentrée à Paris.
J’ai couru au Louvre
pour enfin m’autoriser
à plonger dans des documents
historiques qui allaient m’aider
à écrire un roman
que je couvais depuis un moment.
J’ai passé l’année à vraiment
prendre le temps de m’amuser,
de prendre du plaisir dans ce projet
pour pouvoir l’écrire, le terminer.
Je suis contente, avec cette 2e chose
qu’elle m’a apprise,
d’avoir repris goût
à cette petite excitation
qu’on a quand on est enfant
et qu’on a du plaisir à faire les choses.
La troisième et dernière chose
dont je voulais vous parler aujourd’hui
que ma grand-mère, en tant que mentor,
m’a vraiment apprise,
c’est la communication et la collaboration
qui, selon moi, vont de pair.
Parce que quand on communique vraiment
sur ce qu’on l’on aime, sur ce qu’on est,
sur ce qu’on aime faire,
on est plutôt à même de s’entourer
des personnes qui vont nous aider
dans ces projets et nous soutenir,
qui sont inspirées par les mêmes idées.
Je n’avais pas du tout
compris ça au début.
Je faisais les choses dans mon coin,
gribouillais mon dessin,
ne le montrais pas car
je ne voulais pas déranger les autres.
Et puis, ça ne servait à rien, j’allais
apprendre par moi-même en faisant.
Je sentais bien, encore une fois,
que c’étaient les projets de groupe
qui me faisaient vibrer.
Je viens de monter une exposition
avec des amis
pour le prix Paris-1 Panthéon-Sorbonne
pour l’art contemporain.
Quand on finit un projet de groupe,
on le sent bien, ça fait vibrer.
C’est en montrant, en communiquant, en
collaborant qu’il se passe quelque chose.
Ma grand-mère, pour le coup,
a toujours collaboré comme ça.
Elle allait sur le terrain, allait poser
des questions aux scientifiques.
Elle allait discuter de ses thèses
avec ses étudiants, voyager,
découvrir d'autres manières de voir,
d'autres manières de penser.
D’autres manières de penser,
si on n’en parle pas,
si on reste dans sa niche,
on n’aurait pas accès à ça.
Je sentais bien qu’il fallait que
ces dessins, je les montre en fait,
que je me fasse critiquer,
que je les poste sur Instagram,
que je rencontre des artistes qui
allaient me donner des conseils,
qui allaient peut-être m’encourager
et devenir des nouveaux
mentors plus proches de mes intérêts.
Pareil pour le prix d’art contemporain
qu’on a organisé.
C’est drôle d’être présidente
et de gérer cette équipe,
mais le plus satisfaisant là-dedans,
c’était de produire quelque chose
en commun, de mettre nos talents ensemble,
pour avoir une dotation financière
plus importante,
développer de nouveaux partenariats,
trouver d’autres artistes,
et à la fin, produire une expérience
dont on était fier
parce qu’on avait collaboré,
communiqué, travaillé ensemble,
qu’on s’était amusé et
qu’on s’était engagé avec cœur.
Cette grand-mère, elle m’a inspirée,
et m’a permis de voir les choses en grand,
parfois tellement grand qu’elle me voyait
avocate pour les Droits de l’Homme,
qu’elle voulait que je reprenne
son entreprise et la préside,
que je fasse le tour du monde,
que je parle chinois, anglais, mandarin,
que je développe une théorie
aussi grande que les Lumières,
pas juste aider la marche du monde,
mais que ça soit parfois
presque un peu trop grand.
Je la remercie d’avoir cru en moi et
de croire toujours en moi aujourd’hui,
et d’avoir joué ce rôle de mentor.
Néanmoins comme Perriand
a dû s’éloigner de Le Corbusier
ou Claudel de Rodin,
mais j’ai dû la remercier
et un peu « escape » d’elle,
m’en affranchir pour me permettre
de voler de mes propres ailes,
de trouver un peu ma voix,
ma patte, ma valeur ajoutée,
et de m’autoriser à aller
dans ce qui me passionnait.
J’ai voulu vous parler d’elle aussi car
je pense que des références, des mentors,
on n’a pas forcément besoin d’aller puiser
dans des héros ou des légendes connues.
On n’a pas non plus besoin
d’attendre qu’ils viennent à nous.
Je pense que c’est aussi parfois un effort
de réfléchir à qui joue ce rôle
de mentor pour nous aujourd’hui.
Et peut-être que ma grand-mère
en aura inspiré quelques-uns aujourd’hui
à croire en leurs projets,
à croire en leurs idées,
à s’autoriser à les développer.
Je vous souhaite d’avoir
des figures à admirer, de les trouver,
et ensuite de voler de vos propres ailes,
d’oser briller, déployer vos talents
et en inspirer d’autres après.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)